bonjour jean michel fauvergue bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être en direct avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france emmanuel
macron qui part donc à la rencontre des
français à partir d'aujourd'hui il sera
dans le lot
officiellement c'est pour prendre le
pouls des français qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire tout simplement que le
le prix vient la république est à la
manoeuvre dans le cadre de son travail
et se rend se rend effectivement au
chevet des français pour voir la manière
dont dans les réformes s'applique la
manière dont cette sortie de deux crises
sanitaires et ressenti et il a besoin de
ce contact là c'est normal c'est le
président de la république et ils n'ont
voulu il l'a 7
la salle d'exposition cet instrument a
que de se déplacer dans la pays dans
lequel elle est élue on le rappelle un
les élections présidentielles c'est dans
moins d'un an
les républicains qui ont bien noté aussi
que le chef de l'état fera un passage
dans les hautes france alors qu'on est
en pleine campagne aussi pour les
régionales voyez ce qu'il en disait et
on en parle après après l'envoi des
ministres pour faire campagne
c'est au tour d'emmanuel macron devenir
dans les hauts de france on a plus de
doute que xavier bertrand est l'homme à
abattre
alors est ce que vous vous êtes d'accord
avec ça emmanuel macron qui serait
plutôt le vrp deux des candidats à la
régionale dans son déplacement en france
et dans les autres france mentale
écouter deux choses simples dans notre
pays on est tout le temps en une
campagne politique qui se passe pas face
à un an ou alors c'est très rare qu'un
sentier une campagne politique pour sur
des niveaux différents donc
si le président a un public où les
membres du gouvernement ou un certain
nombre d'hommes politiques ne devaient
plus se déplacer entre entre chaque
campagne politique on n'irait plus la
première chose c'est la deuxième chose
c'est que le président la république à
touches quels qu'ils soient et quel que
quelques esprits dans a jugé que c'est
toujours déplacées dans son pays à la
rencontre bien de céder des français
kiki et a besoin de ce contact là
maintenant tu viennes j'ai bien compris
la la question qui viennent dans l'eau
de france dans le france l'île de france
sont une région aussi comme une autre il
et je vois pas en quoi elles ne
pourraient pas se déplacer dans le
france maintenant que là que la bataille
politique régionale fasse rage au niveau
des hauts de france est une réalité bien
évidemment il ya des élèves grillades et
des gens qui sont qui sont déjà inscrits
dans cette campagne la clavier vers son
qui fait campagne
on a notre tête de liste on a des
membres du gouvernement qui sont
inscrits dans cette campagne là c'est
aussi cinq ans dans notre pays que de
quelques des membres du gouvernement
ceux se coltine à la réalité du terrain
tquel et quelle est la stratégie dans
marche
on l'a vu contre le rassemblement
national dans le sud contre les
républicains dans le nord le premier
ministre jean castex a été interpellé
hier à l'assemblée par bertrand pancher
du groupe liberté et territoires
regarder je vais te regarde les
partisans d'un face à face avec le fn
on ne peut pas lutter contre l'extrême
droite en courant derrière elle a
fracturé la gauche puis la droite
gare à ne pas détruire la démocratie sur
le premier ministre il reste un peu
moins d'un an avant l'élection
présidentielle
et vous pouvez en faire encore une année
utile pour tenter de rassembler les
français
mais il faut agir maintenant car nous ne
sortirons pas collectivement de ce
bourbier sont un triple choc
démocratique économique et sociale
encore répondez-vous à cela à force de
fracturer la gauche et la droite est ce
que la république en marche ne joue pas
un peu aux apprentis sorciers
moi je sais ce que je constate c'est que
la gauche depuis pas mal de temps déjà a
été assez assez majeur pour se fracturer
elle même et en y mettant beaucoup de
coeur et beaucoup de beaucoup de force
et donc qu'à terme elle a récolté ce
qu'est ce qu'elle a sauvé et ça c'est la
faute de personne et je pense qu'à un
certain moment les gens qui est qui qui
se revendique 2,7 cette tendance-là
devrait devrait peut-être ouvrir les
yeux et c'est de se demander pourquoi on
en est rendu là
concernant la droite je constate aussi
que on a non pas un chemin identique
mais
la droite est en train de se fracturer
parce que une partie du programme en
particulier sur la sécurité et ça c'est
un domaine que je connais bien a été
préempté prise en compte par la majorité
actuelle qui est une majorité très
pragmatique le but le but d'en marche le
but de notre majorité c'est de faire en
sorte que les français souhaitent en
sécurité donc on a en a on a voté un
certain nombre de choses pour lesquelles
quelques fois nous avons été suivis par
une partie de la droite qui qui était en
ligne avec elle même et qui continuer à
travailler sur les sur les vecteurs sur
lequel avait toujours travaillé puis
notre lien entre partie de cette droite
là qui s'y opposent et saint-roch mans
qui était complètement en contradiction
avec elle même et qui a préféré
lg on le voit maintenant avoir des
paroles assez ambigu attention delà de
l'extrême droite
donc je pense que la responsabilité de
la fracturation
ou plutôt de la fracture part dans la
réussite éviter la fracture à droite
comme à gauche
elle est avant tout une zone de droite
et de gauche à certains pas tous bien
évidemment qui n'ont pas su prendre le
tournant quand cela est qu'il est c'est
sûr on va parler de l'île -de-france
précisément vous êtes sur la liste de
laurent saint martin pour la république
en marche dimanche il s'est agacé d'un
scrutin est dit-il déformé par les
ambitions présidentielles des candidats
regardez moi je suis candidat face à six
concurrents tous n'ont qu'une obsession
et qu'un seul mot à la bouche
emmanuel macron ils sont tous candidats
contre emmanuel macron quand je suis
candidat pour ma région
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec lui
est ce que c'est normal de deux
postulats un mandat que l'on risque de
ne pas assurer est-ce que c'est
acceptable pour les français selon vous
d'abord je suis d'accord avec avec leurs
enfants martin qui est un formidable
candidat de la majorité en ile de france
qui fait une campagne une campagne
formidable aussi je suis sur sa liste en
position éligible à je tiens à le
préciser sur sa sur sa liste mais parce
que parce que j'y crois et parce que
dans la mesure du possible c'est à tout
le monde de tirer un peu les suffrages
vers averse est cette formidable listes
sont son positionnement
effectivement sur des sur des candidats
qui ont d'autres idées que là que là que
la régionales s'explique s'explique
parce que les les enjeux sont
suffisamment importants dans les
régionales on a de formidables enjeux
surtout en ile de france la région la la
la la plus simple la plus riche de
france
on a des enjeux suffisamment important
de vous interrompre malheureusement
c'est les temps de parole du csa qui
nous impose des temps précis pour pour
les régions merci en tout cas de cette
réponse
on va parler de cette campagne pour les
régionales où la sécurité est l'enjeu
principal
tous les jours on l'a vu il ya de
nouvelles règles sont trop jeunes il y a
eu cette agression d'un couple ira
marseille et ses propos racistes
communautaire contre un livreur qui a
aussi été agressée à cergy l'auteur à
d'ailleurs été mise en garde à vue
gérald permanence en est félicité
regarder merci aux policiers sous
l'autorité judiciaire pour leur réaction
rapide
le racisme ne doit jamais rester impuni
le racisme doit jamais rester impuni
l'homme était déjà connu des services de
police pour outrage cure que risque-t-il
concrètement faut-il une sentence
exemplaire et laquelle le cas le cas
échéant on va vous savez les fait de
l'effet de racisme sont suffisamment
important pour être pour être condamné
d'une manière manière importante aussi
le racisme c'est pas seulement ils sont
passés pas seulement un délit pénal
c'est aussi s'attaquer à notre
universalisme à s'attaquer à ce qu'on a
construit à ce que notre pays a
construit depuis depuis des siècles
c'est à dire l'égalité entre entre les
uns entre les autres l'égalité
hommes-femmes aussi c'est quelque chose
d'important et que chacun ne soient pas
inquiétés
pour sa provenance en particulier sa
provenance est unique pour ce à quoi ils
croient et tour son époux recensés et
c'est bien évidemment un combat
sociétale à ne pas laisser tomber face à
je le constate des positionnements des
positionnements on va dire politique
pour certains déposent des
positionnements d'opinion publique qui
sont des possibles des positionnements
qu'issus de bus tice racisme racialise
de plus en plus savez quand on emploie
des mots comme racialisée des mots comme
[Musique]
antisionisme tout ça tout ça veut dire
la même chose c'est lé mot vintage pour
dire racisme et et antisémitisme et donc
il est évidemment important de réagir
là-dessus la police l'a fait rapidement
sous l'autorité des magistrats
la justice a va être saisie c'est à elle
de juger cet individu là
kiki avec a tenu ces propos qui sont
complètement hors contexte hors d'époque
est particulièrement choquant gérald
darmanin qui qui se rend en tunisie
aujourd'hui avec le premier ministre est
là la sécurité et l'immigration seront
abordés comment contraindre la tunisie à
récupérer ses ressortissants selon vous
a accusé de terrorisme
pour l'instant elle refuse c'est un
enjeu bien sûr c'est un an je mange je
tiens je tiens à préciser qu'elle ne
refuse pas surtout toutes les toutes les
personnes qui lui sont présentés
mais mais c'est bien sûr qu'il faut
renforcer les liens il faut que les pays
les pays qui ont
mais qui ont toutes deux un camp que
l'on que l'on doit expulser puisse là
doivent doivent les reprendre c'est une
obligation internationale et doivent
donc se plier à leurs obligations
internationales pour nous c'est
important
vous savez que depuis le début du
quinquennat et sept dernières années le
nombre d'expulsions s'est accélérée pour
pour des motifs de de ce type là vous
savez aussi quand on va voir un certain
nombre de ce ressortissant de gens de
gens qui vont sortir des prisons alors
qu'ils soient terroristes où qu'ils
soient condamnés pour des infractions
importante
certains ont été condamnés par le juge
d'ailleurs l'interdiction du territoire
national
il faut qu'on la mette en application il
faut que les pays de deux d'origine de
ces de ces gens-là accepte ne refuse pas
leur leur arrivée dans leur pays pour
qu'ils ne refusent pas est ce qu'il faut
est ce qu'il faut faire preuve de
fermeté notamment en conditionnant les
aides au développement
il faut faire preuve surtout de beaucoup
de diplomatie en un certain nombre de
choses sur lesquelles on peut on peut
travailler la tunisie par exemple on est
la france a des liens étroits qui sont
aussi des liens économiques des liens
touristiques avec avec la tunisie
je pense qu'on a un certain nombre
d'enjeux communs que l'on peut que l'on
peut sur lesquels on peut échanger avec
un grand pays comme la tunisie
maintenant je veux répondre précisément
à votre question n'est pas là ne pas la
laisser de côté la l'aide publique au
développement
dans certains pays et est importante
je pense pas forcément la tunisie mais à
beaucoup d'autres pays en particulier
des pays en afrique un acide aide
publique au développement est importante
ça peut être aussi un effectivement un
certain moment un enjeu
un enjeu pour réguler une immigration
débridée
jean castex qui va également parler
immigration on sait que la tunisie à 15%
de ressortissants tunisiens qui arrivent
illégalement en europe
chaque année est ce que là aussi il peut
y avoir un levier pour contraint en tout
cas ces pays dont la tunisie à retenir
ses candidats au départ témoin j'ai été
avec j'ai été policier pendant 40 ans et
j'ai travaillé en particulier à la
police aux frontières où je m'occupais
de l'international et donc de ces
questions là c'est un problème très très
difficile à résoudre parce que pour
autant les et en particulier la tunisie
les pays du maghreb d'une manière
générale ne maîtrisent pas tous dans
leur pays comme nous d'ailleurs ne
maîtrisons pas tout non plus dans montre
notre pays la liberté de de partir des
uns et les autres ne pas et c'est
difficilement en pêchable par des
gouvernements ou par des processus
particulier donc en à ces mouvements-là
qui qui se font le les relations
internationales pour les limiter le plus
possible son teint sont intéressantes
maintenant et ont conscience que on ne
pourra pas éviter le départ de personnes
qui veulent absolument partir vers elle
un pseudo eldorado ou à partir tout
court des horizons dont on va aborder la
haye la crise sanitaire à présent si
vous voulez bien avec ce chiffre en
grande bretagne aucun morts recensés en
24 heures c'est la même chose pour
israël
en france ça baisse mais on en est loin
quand même avec plus d'une centaine de
morts au quotidien le gouvernement
aurait-il pu faire mieux selon vous
c'est un c c'est une question que que
les journalistes se pose depuis
le début de la crise sanitaire c'est à
dire il ya deux un peu plus de deux ans
un pour des raisons diverses et variées
et sur un certain nombre de thèmes
différents sur les sur les vaccins sur
les masques sur ça revient de manière
redondante chaque fois alors est ce
qu'on aurait pu faire mieux
je ne sais pas ce qui a été fait c'est
une protection de la part de l'est de
l'état comme jamais il n'ya eu
auparavant parce qu'on était confronté à
une situation qui n'existait pas
auparavant ou qui a existé il ya très
longtemps l'état protecteur s'est
déployée avec un président de la
république qui a été particulièrement
offrons un gouvernement aussi des
gouvernements successifs pardon qui ont
été particulièrement au front je
constate aujourd'hui que la situation
est en train de s'améliorer
là la vaccination est en train de monter
en puissance il faut continuer dans ce
domaine là et c'est avec une vaccination
importante qu'on sortira de cette de
cette crise là mais attention là ce que
celui qui commande aujourd'hui
réellement c'est le côté doux l'aco vite
comme vous comme vous préférez et
diverses formes de mutation en soyons
vigilants ne baissons pas la garde
surtout dans ce domaine il ya le variant
indien qui inquiète aussi les
britanniques à présent on va pas rester
ses producteurs de masques français y
sont en colère parce qu'on leur avait
demandé de produire massivement en
pleine pandémie et aujourd'hui ils
n'arrivent plus à écouler leurs stocks
distille parce que le gouvernement
achète en chine
alors est ce que le gouvernement aurait
dû privilégier le made in france selon
moi j'ai passé ces renseignements là je
suis allé visiter
il ya 2 mois de ça un producteur
français de match sur ma circonscription
sur la ville de collégiens dans ma
circonscription dans 77 en seine et
marne et qui karaboue de moins qu'avec
remporter un certain nombre de marchés
on lui a demandé de produire local et il
en local donc j'ai pas j'ai pas cette
information là c'est une information que
que je prends à travers les médias mais
voilà je j'ai eu un peu de mal à j'ai un
peu de mal à me positionner parce que
moi mon expérience personnelle les faits
démontre exactement deux confrères c'est
vrai que plusieurs nous on a eu
plusieurs producteurs de masques au
téléphone qui confirme cette information
est ce qu'on n'aurait pas dû primer
léger et on peut toujours faire marche
arrière bien sûr mais privilégier les
filières françaises selon il faut il
faut le faire ou pas a bien évidemment
bien évidemment ça a été fait lady par
le président de la république et par le
gouvernement bien évidemment qu'il faut
privilégier des seniors française qu'il
faut relocaliser mais pas seulement pour
nice pour pour les masques pour pour le
sanitaire
le syndicat des ja c'est important vous
avez vu qu'on va produire des vaccins en
france il n'est pas trop tard parce que
le marché du vaccin va être un marché
qui va être un marché perpétuelle en
tout cas tant que cette menace sera la
rue mais bien sûr qu'il faut produire en
france en europe et favoriser la
production relocaliser les productions
locales bien évidemment merci beaucoup
jean-michel fauvergue d'avoir répondu ce
matin en direct par téléphone
malheureusement à nos questions
malheureusement sur rt france ça sera
pour une prochaine fois
merci beaucoup en tout cas